[Music]
all right hello listeners this is
plastic pills and you are on the pale
pod everyone
i've read it you're bugging me you want
to lose content so today is a very big
day for
us because we have our first celebrity
guest and i'm sure he will object to
that term
uh but if you ever do any academic work
on deliz
uh you will know of him so joining us
from the far side of the commonwealth
is deliz scholar and the founder
founder and editor i believe of the de
liz studies journal
or more correctly the delize in guitaree
studies journal ian buchanan so what's
up ian and
how do you feel about being a celebrity
guest
well all my dreams have come true i
think um
i i think the day when dylasian and
celebrity go together will be
a very happy day indeed i'm uh looking
at you and envy sitting there in
t-shirts as we struggle through our
our kind of approximation of winter
where the temperatures here today have
plunged to a very low
to 10 degrees yeah we're up around uh
what would you say chris around 30
32 yep it's about 30 yes plus 32 yep
it's being in um calgary once and it was
like april and it was 10 degrees
and i was absolutely freezing
and um everybody was like oh let's go
outside and have a barbecue and they're
standing around their shorts and i was
just like are you off your mind
this is as cold as it ever gets in
australia that's early early spring
weather out in calgary
since we mentioned tim helping me out
with this interview today is
vitalist schlingen and you can object to
the term all you wish but it's chris
who you may have heard in previous
episodes um
somewhat of an expert on de liz in his
own right how's it going chris
it's all right i'm excited to be here
and i'm excited to
be talking to ian and me plastic pills
if you know anything about content
you know the tingly feelings i get for
deliz
so for the sake of this interview i'm
gonna play the role of this state
a little bit as academics tend to get a
little jargony if left to their own
devices
and i will caveat that by saying i'm not
a very experienced interviewer and i
have no pretenses
otherwise alas you are stuck with me
so first ian um you have a new book
coming out
uh what is that and do you want to say a
few words about it
uh so it's going to be called assemblage
theory
and method and it's in production now
and it's
i believe going to be available as a an
object to own and cherish
um in september it's been a long time
coming i can't believe how long it's
been
that i've been working on this book that
kind of
i began to realize just didn't want to
be written um
alternatively i didn't want to write it
i'm not sure yeah
but i set myself the task of writing a
book that um
that i liked and it turned out i was
fairly fussy about what i liked
and i must have written at least
you know 150 000 words to end up with a
50 000 word book so there was
a lot of draft material that has
accumulated in
folders on my laptop that never made the
final cut
and so some of what i know you for and
maybe our listeners do too
is for your practical applications of
delusion theory so delis on the internet
is your work that i'm most familiar with
is this
uh also a would you call or could you
make that divide between the practical
application and a more theoretical text
then where would you situate that
if you accept the spectrum um i mean the
spectrum is is kind of arbitrary but i
think it's
it's useful nonetheless to think about
it um i mean i
i don't find particularly fascinating a
lot of the conversations
that people have about ontology and so
forth i kind of like happy to accept
that things
exist and not worry too much about the
state of
of that um and for me that's that's
the theoretical end of spectrum i think
it's it's good and necessary work but it
doesn't get me out of bed in the morning
um but i guess i'm at the other end of
the spectrum
of thinking well once we know about
these things what can we do with them
and how will it
actually change how we think about the
world how might it shape a politics how
might it
help us to do analysis and that does
interest me
um and i've been for a different project
that i've moved on to now
i'm writing a kind of overall
introduction to
cultural theory which i um foolishly
promised to do about 10 years ago and
have now finally found time to actually
do
um so i'm kind of been reading a lot of
foucault and i've been reading all his
um his lectures uh the whole lecture
series
and they're really quite fascinating but
i mean i think what's really fascinating
about fukom and
and what clearly was um
that you know a kind of point of
intersection between their work for
foucault and dolores was the fact that
that foucault really wanted to on the
one hand do theoretical work but on the
other hand
you know try to use that theoretical
work to understand practical things like
imprisonment and and psychiatry and
and the stuff that really fascinates me
is the work around governmentality
so in my book i use very um
kind of concrete examples as a way of
trying to think about
um de lesser's work and and i've always
said you know
in every forum wherever i've spoken that
to me
if i can't use dillers to try to
understand something kind of practical
and real
then i don't really see the point um and
so
for me it's kind of important to try to
make that connection
but i also think that both these and
guitare themselves were kind of like
you know we're not just doing this for
no reason we're doing it because we want
to
create something that people can use to
make an intervention into the world
um and because you mentioned his name i
i often say we're talking about de luz
when
of course in this context it means
delize and guitaree
unfortunately sometimes he's forgotten
but this book if i'm not mistaken that
you're writing it's on
thousand plateaus right um i guess one
could say it's mostly about a thousand
plateaus but
um because that's that is the book that
we associate with the word
um assemblage although it's present
in antioquis ii uh it just wasn't
translated
as assemblage in that book translated
differently so
a lot of people don't think of
assemblage as being part of
um anti-editors but it was in fact there
one could also say that it was not um
marked out
in the same way um so you you might
argue that it wasn't really there as a
concept
yet um but certainly the word was
okay and um because i'm not sure exactly
what the familiarity of our
listeners will be but let's say
you sit down you've just ordered 1000
plateaus
from an evil ever expanding company off
of
off of the internet and you have this on
your desk
and what is someone supposed to do when
they open this up and they see
titles like i don't know the geology of
morals and
body without organs and the refrain and
these
odd titles with weird dates next to them
how do you how would you suggest that
someone who has
no familiarity with this who opens it up
and says
how how the hell is this philosophy how
should they proceed
yeah well i guess they're probably
asking the wrong question um you know
whether it's philosophy or not
philosophy doesn't seem to me to be
a very important question um because
again that's kind of arbitrary as well
uh look when i when i first read um
antiopus
um which i read before i read a thousand
plateaus
but i read it mostly because and this
was when i was a graduate student
because other graduate students were
reading it and i was fairly sure that it
was going to be nonsense
because i thought the people who were
reading it were idiots um
and so i read it mostly so that i could
dismiss it and
and just you know justify to myself that
they really were idiots reading all this
fashionable nonsense
um and so anyway i read it and and to my
absolute surprise
i was like completely blown away by it
um
and i think that that experience of just
just being
kind of overwhelmed by the
sheer quantity of new ideas and
provocative sentences
and so forth i mean i think that in
itself is a kind of intellectual thrill
that
that happens really rarely like it's not
often that you pick up a book and you
think
damn that was just like a wild ride i
don't really know what it said
or what it meant but it just kind of
overwhelms me
and i think you got to go with that like
you know don't try and
and make sense of it straight away or
even think that that's possible
just go with a wild ride initially and
just enjoy that and
and be full of the ideas that it that it
sparks in you
and and not worry you know have you got
it right or got it wrong
um you know that kind of scholarly work
comes later
but just to be um thrilled with the kind
of
stimulation of just such a rich amount
of ideas and and
i think a thousand plateaus is is much
much richer in a sense than an
antioquist in terms of the you know if
you were kind of thinking about it
uh in terms of like a thriller minute
there's the antidifference
is a bit of a is a slower ride by
comparison but a thousand plateaus is
just
just stunning like you know once you get
into it i remember reading it
and just being like wow where is all
this stuff coming from
and later on you know i kind of you know
started to learn more about the process
of writing it
and that in itself is quite interesting
like you know de los angeles together
for seven years
um during which time they produced a
thousand plateaus
um and you know all the students would
bring texts and you can you can see some
of these videos
um on youtube and so forth now and it's
like a room full of people it's like 40
50 students
and they would bring texts and that sort
of thing so you know when you step back
and think
how on earth do they manage to cover so
much ground well the answer is that they
didn't do it all by themselves they did
it with the help of their students and
they just
simply churned everything into this kind
of huge synthetic
thing which is a thousand plateaus so
there's a there's a lot of reasons why
it's it's thrilling and confusing and
and whatever and it's because it
genuinely is a collective production
that's a good point and i didn't
actually know that it was that
assembled or assembled in that way
um chris i want to ask you a question a
second because i think
you can correct me if i'm wrong but i
think this is not your favorite
work by de las at least and you
tend more towards his uh what you call
it the conceptual biographies of
different personas or berkshire
nietzsche spinoza so as someone who
likes
those kinds of books how do you how do
you read or pick up or process this book
well i think i i think um a thousand
plateaus is a
it's not really my favorite book but
it's a it's a brilliant text like in the
introduction
um the liz and watari are talking about
how they're in the habit of using their
names but they're using this text as a
wii
in order for them to you know so you
don't just read it like a book you
you can open up the the rhizome or micro
politics and
and take a look at specific concepts
that are being
um unraveled in the text but for me i
always like the the kind of monographs
that belize has written so that the
first one that i
ever read that blew me away was
expressionism in philosophy on spinoza
and he and here for me i was enraptured
by the lewis in this idea of
expressivity
and you know emanuel delanda talks a lot
about this idea of expressivity
but it it was you know de la's working
through an early modern thinker and
you know working through the concepts of
imminence working through
um spinoza's you know concept of the
connatus
and making it very modern and at the
same time giving you such an explicit
and informed understanding of
of the thinker and also a little bit of
an unfaithful
rendition of the thinker a lot of people
might say he does this also with hume
leibniz in the book of the fold um and
often people who dedicate their their
staunchy
academic career to these thinkers say
well you're reading them
you're misinterpreting it yeah they
always laugh about the fact that
whenever they read a thinker there's
always some kind of
backwards buggery going on that's uh
you know with a thinker okay so back to
the text at hand
uh thousand plateaus as you've probably
taught this text for a number of years
in talking about misinterpretation or
interpretation and are they the same
thing but with this book it's referenced
in so many theoretical disciplines
from music studies
cultural studies gender studies
post-humanism do you ever think that
this is too
liberally applied as a text or do you
think that this is exactly what the
lewis and qatari
would have hoped would be done with it
yeah look this is a question that i get
asked a lot um uh
for fairly obvious reasons uh look i i
wrote a paper
a little while ago um about the use
of deluxe within human geography
uh particularly around the use of the
concept of the assemblage
and the kind of point i made about that
i wanted to make in this particular
article
was that there was this um sort of
survey article talking about
all the the different ways for which
assemblage had been used in human
geography
um and whilst it acknowledged that that
delusionatari had been a source
of of this concept of the assemblage it
didn't
actually refer to their work at all
um and so one of the things that that i
i find problematic and this is something
that i try to
deal with through the journal as well is
that
there there does seem to be a need for
uh
primary readings like a lot of the the
kind of the growth of the the kind of
references to jules and guitaria through
secondary readings it's not actually
reading to those guitar for themselves
it's reading so and so is reading your
so-and-so's reading and and so forth so
it kind of multiplies
not just the misunderstandings but it
also multiplies the trivialities and the
trivializations
um yeah so i think that is that is
really a problem it leads to really bad
scholarship when
when you prepare to just accept
so-and-so's word like i think it's
important to acknowledge other people's
ideas and engage with those ideas
but not to simply accept them as a
substitute for
reading the original text yourself yeah
um
as as for the question of whether or not
it's interpretation or misinterpretation
i mean you know you mentioned earlier
that people
some people are not happy with or find
problematic
uh delicious readings of spinoza or hume
or whatever
um but i've never read anybody who says
that he got them
totally wrong like was he even reading
spinoza or had he even you know heard of
hume or whatever
and delos himself said that it was
important that people always recognize
that the offspring of his work was
recognizable that you could see that it
really was
something from spinoza or something from
hume or whatever
and so that was important for him so his
interpretations
were not just free liberal inventions
they really were
a very strong attempt to bring out
something new
but in a way that that showed a clear
recognition of the original text so i
think
that's kind of the the space that we
should be in with the lesser kotari to
say well look
we don't have to slavishly reproduce
what they did and we should certainly be
trying to find
new and interesting things that we can
extract from it but if we're going to do
that that doesn't mean we should just go
off and invent something that
really owes nothing to their thinking
and that's i guess it's a fairly hard
space to do
to define exactly but i think um
for example you know i probably
reasonably well known for having a
20-year long argument with delander
but at least part of the reasons why i
disagree profoundly with what he does
is that his his starting point like even
with this the war in the age of
intelligent machines book which
in many ways is very interesting but the
thing that always troubled me is that he
starts by saying
well we're not going to talk about
desire and
and jane bennett does more or less the
same thing in her work you think well
how on earth can you connect what you're
doing with de los muertari if your
starting point
is to eliminate their starting point so
to me that's that's
you know kind of veering off in a
radically different direction which no
longer can
claim to owe any kind of point of
contact with the origin
so for me that's what it's about like
you know how are you dealing with the
absolutely fundamental aspects of
diversity's work
and what can you do that's new and
original with that
um and just to reference this this
concept of desire because this is
something that we have
or that i have at least talked about a
lot before uh gutarie was trained
by lacan and capitalism and desire was
the whole point of the first book of
this
series um anti-oedipus um so
what would you say is the significance
of desire and why is it inextricable
from
uh getting the purpose of these texts
um so i guess the the
the reason it's inextricable is because
it is the founding premise of anti
editors that that
in a sense you could say that the
founding premise of antidepressants
the history of the world can be
understood as
um the kind of configurations of desire
that have been produced historically
um that you can't understand history if
you can't understand how desire plays
its part
in history which then begs the question
of what is desire
um the only sort of significant
theoretical difference
that uh foucault and de los ever had was
around the question of desire versus
pleasure um they had personal
differences which related to
uh palestine um dallas was
completely pro-palestinian pro-yes
arafat and so forth whereas foucault had
probably not it would be unfair to say
zionist tendencies but nonetheless
he certainly had sympathies for that
position that meant he could not
be fully um pro-palestinian so that was
that was as i understand it the cause of
their major falling out and
the reason why they stopped speaking to
one another um
but nonetheless going back to the
question of desire and pleasure
uh so if you think about uh
freud like the premise of psychoanalysis
saying well how can we explain why
people do what they do
and and so freud's hypothesis is
essentially
he starts by thinking it must be because
people
obtain pleasure from what they do um
but then this idea runs into a number of
roadblocks
fairly quickly because it becomes quite
difficult to explain
if you say to somebody uh you know why
do you like being a handyman and
renovating bathrooms on the weekend
it sounds idiotic to say i get pleasure
out of it and to sort of say well
somehow that connects to you know sexual
pleasure in in some way just
it just sounds odd um and and it
as a way of trying to explain what
people do it doesn't work very well
so eventually what freud did was to say
well actually it's not really the search
for
pleasure that dominates um people's
lives but rather it's
it's a question of trying to find an
equilibrium
in their lives between pleasure and
unpleasure between the things that
really kind of
make us feel uncomfortable attract
self-reproach
um you know this is the stuff that that
jesus always talks about you know when
you're the home handyman
and you turn this the spanner too far
and the tap breaks off and you're like
oh why am i such an idiot
and so forth so there's a you know
self-reproach and pleasure all mixed up
into one thing
and so what we want is equilibrium so in
the end
you know freud's theory is a theory of
this
this is where the idea of the nirvana
principle the death drive and all these
things come out
is a theory of equilibrium but basically
we just don't want to be too
kind of stressed out too stimulated all
the time so we're not actually searching
for pleasure
really rather we're trying to find a
balance between too much pleasure too
much unpleasure
and so on so that's the premise like the
whole of psychoanalysis comes back to
this
one kind of basic hypothesis
so when de les and quitari come along
they say well this doesn't really
explain things
well enough so we need to to rethink
that
um and so they're kind of interested in
what freud is trying to say but they
don't think he's got it 100
right um la khan comes along and says
well
really we we can only explain this uh in
terms of
uh and this is an absolute cliche but
it's not completely wrong
but we can only explain this in terms of
lack that
what we lack is what motivates us and so
we and you can understand that what i
lack is peace of mind therefore i have
to do these things in order to
attain peace of mind but it's it's as to
those who
argue it's a kind of a theory of
diminishing returns like you can never
actually obtain this particular state of
mind that you're trying to obtain so you
you live your life in a perpetual sense
of deficit
and blessing i don't think that's very
satisfactory either
so you've got equilibrium on the one
hand deficit on the other hand
neither of these theories really explain
things that well
so then they come along and say well how
could we do things differently
and at this point they then turn to marx
and they extract from him the idea of
surplus value
now this to me it has never really been
dealt with very much
in the secondary literature under mutari
and i have to admit
i haven't done enough of it uh work on
this myself
but i was recently reading um david
harvey's two
companion volumes to marx's capital uh
volumes one and two
and it suddenly struck me that really
that is the key we're like we actually
need to go and look at
the theory of surplus value and see what
did the lesson better extract from that
that would help us to understand this
idea of desire
and so if you think about what is
surplus value surface value
comes from the idea of investing
something
and receiving a return that is
that exceeds the original investment
um and in fact lesser guitar do use the
idea of
investment of desire so their word is on
vestis mall
which is a uh a kind of the french
rendering
of the original um uh so in english we
use the greek word because of the
weird stretchy translation which
translated all the german words into
greek words
so we think of this as cathexis which is
when
desire achieves a achieves a kind of a
response
and and a realization we call that
cathexis
um but in french that was translated as
anvestis long
but what's interesting is that the
investism means both
an investment in this sort of
straightforward sense of going to the
bank and putting money in the bank and
expecting a return
but also and this is the part that's
really crucial it means
a military occupation so the original
german
bazetsung also meant occupation
and and that is i think what's really
really interesting about that
so what desire does is it occupies
it occupies a space and it it expects
the kind of a return
and that's what surplus value is so
there's this whole new way i think of
thinking about how desire works
um and and this for me then connects up
to notions of territory and so on and so
forth it comes later
but really to see desire as a kind of
military occupation that
it finds these territories that it
occupies it and it extracts a kind of a
return from it
and it's this surplus value idea that is
to me super interesting
and has not been really dealt with
enough in how we think about de los
angeles idea of desire
um so when we're skirting around this
the question of desire and how to
structure it in
in the first book not not the thousand
plateaus but an anti-oedipus
they go into this notion of the
the triadic structure that
psychoanalysis brings
so the uh triangulation yeah the mummy
daddy syndrome right so the edible yeah
the edible triangle
of this mommy daddy thing um and they go
so far as to call this
an instrument of the state which is this
uh
i don't want to say the wrong word
either molar or molecular family
um and this is a version of state um and
they also
discuss specific philosophers as
state philosophers i'm just going to
suggest here
that this book a thousand plateaus is
not
meant to be a state text so could you
explain a little bit
how you see this as an anti-state text
or how they might have seen it as an
anti-state text and how that
explains the structure that it has well
yes i mean to me this has never seemed
like a particularly
interesting way of thinking about this
book because i think it's
it kind of owes its owes its uh sense
and its meaning
to uh to its moment right like when it
came out in
in 1980 but it was really produced
through the 1970s
when i think people were
more consciously anti-state than we are
now
and which is why it's super interesting
to go back and read these focusing
lectures like these lectures were all
given in the 1970s right
um the early ones that i've been reading
and
and so what you hear for code talking
about is to say well look we can't
really understand this idea of the state
if we start out from the premise that
the state exists
and in a sense that's exactly what
delivers saying that we can't sort of
start from the idea that the state just
simply exists
um and then their methods
differ slightly but their principle is
the same so foucault says well
we have to look at the various practices
and techniques and procedures
that kind of give coherence to this idea
that we have of the state
but we more or less have to recognize
that the state as such does not exist
and this is what's really fascinating
about the idea of governmentality
on the other side doesn't matter also
saying well look the state exists as an
idea
but in reality it exists as all these
machines and assemblages and apparatuses
and so forth so
there is a huge amount of crossover
between de los angel
in this period of the 70s right like you
know if you read in the introduction
of discipline and punish uh foucault
explicitly says i could not have written
this book if it was not for anti-editors
and then likewise as you're reading in a
thousand plateaus they
acknowledge a debt to foucault
particularly around the idea of the sort
of apparatus in the machine
but say that they disagree with him on
this issue of pleasure versus
desire but nonetheless there is a huge
degree of
crossover between their works and you
know i haven't really seen anybody talk
about this but um you know like when you
read
the letters um people say it's like
one of these final pieces but i doubt
that it was um
the society of control paper now in the
society of control paper he says
but foucault himself was already saying
you know the disciplinary apparatuses
had already disappeared um which is true
right like i mean foucault says
in in these lectures discipline came to
an end somewhere in the middle of the
18th century
and this new thing governmentality
biopolitics uh
followed afterwards but then i was just
reading this morning in fact
in at the opening of his book um
society must be defended he says so what
we're going to talk about this year has
is this new form of power that has come
into being
since the end of world war ii since the
end of nazism and so forth
and really that is control society and
that is what de leos was talking about
is when he says
this new thing called control society
came into being
you know following world war ii and it's
precisely what what foucault was talking
about
as well and if you read the other book
the birth of biopolitics
there's like three or four chapters
talking about the birth of neoliberalism
and again it's really surprising that
nobody has really
said much about this like when we talk
about neoliberalism we tend to then go
turn to david harvey or somebody like
that for an analysis of it
but already here in the early 1970s
foucault was saying well neoliberalism
is the extension of the idea of the
market to every aspect
of daily life and so i think you know
when we think about
delusion foucault we should really look
at this intersection that we're really
working on a very similar kind of a
problem
which is how do we understand this new
form of power that arose in the
post-world war ii
uh era and the idea of the state no
longer seems adequate
and it doesn't seem adequate because we
now live in a time
when really the state's only function
and delays in guitarists say this is to
provide models of realization for
capital
so the state no longer governs as it
as it were doesn't control people but
rather it provides the kind of
regulations that capital wants in order
to
maintain uh profitability and foco again
talks about this in terms of
the sort of paradox of freedom like how
much freedom does the market want
um and how much restriction does it want
you think well the markets always say
they want absolute freedom
but that's you know completely false
they don't want absolute freedom
they want freedom like an individual
company wants enough freedom to make
money
but it doesn't want other people to have
freedom to take away their business
yeah so there is this kind of
contradiction in the heart of the idea
of the free market
the free market is not free at all the
free market is free for me to make money
but free from you trying to take my
money right um and and that's the new
kind of society of control
we'll just fall onto binaries just
because it passes or advances the
conversation but interpretation versus
misinterpretation you're saying a good
interpretation is always going to
uh trace back to desire as the origin
of uh the project the philosophical
project
insofar as they're dealing with the
losing guitarist work 100 i don't think
you can avoid that
um in in de les's work that he does
particularly the work prior to
antidepress
desire plays much less of a part one
might say that he was
working his way towards the work on
desire
and you know the stuff through the book
on spinoza and so forth one can easily
say well
a lot of what he wants to say about
desire comes through from his reading of
spinoza but it also then is a departure
from spinoza
um look i'm fine i'm i'm fine with
people departing from delos and saying
like i i've done
this with dollars and now i'm going to
go and do something different i think
that's you know legitimate scholarly
work
um the problem i had was but when people
say well this is delays but you
you look at what they've done and you
think well manifestly that is not delays
you have
taken all kinds of shortcuts and you you
have overlooked
um crucial aspects of his work that
would that
make his work what it is so that for me
is a problem
chris you've been silent for a while do
you want to jump in on here on anything
ian just just to jump back to uh um
desire here for a second in uh la la
becide i'm gonna butcher the french
language here
in in um d um
the liz uses the word to delir i think
i think he distinguishes desire from
delir
uh and and it's claire parnet
one of his students who's asking him the
differences between the two
could you care to elaborate on that or
yeah i don't think claire was a student
right like she was sort of a
friend and a journalist i might be wrong
about that
um so the distinction between desire and
dalia
or usually translated as some form of
delirium or it's often left untranslated
because there is no
corresponding word in english as such
is quite difficult i think to follow but
i think what
what they're saying with the idea of um
delirium and and this comes through in
antiochus where they're talking about
um uh talking about can't in particular
where kant was quite interested in in
what he saw as the sort of pure
products of the mind that the things
that the mind could just create out of
nothing
um and this would be the source of all
creativity the problem is that
as they see it can't dismisses this as a
kind of form of madness and
as a problem the difference between
the desire and the delirium then is this
kind of intersection
um around the idea of the productions of
the mind and i think this is the other
crucial aspect of desire that
really needs to be worked through but i
think this is why they turn to the idea
of
surplus value as a try as a way of
trying to theorize this notion of
production that that
if the mind is a factory as they say and
it's producing things
then what is the function and the role
of those things and and how
might we think about it um and so the
mind produces things which in turn
it consumes um and so that really is
then the
where delirium comes into it because
delirium ah
is the the products of the mind but it
is also the way by which we consume
those products um and it has to do with
then
to the degree to which we are able to
recognize them
as solely the products of our mind or as
having some kind of anchor point
uh outside of the mind and so whenever i
i teach versions of this
at least camps and so forth i always say
that like when somebody
is neurotic um and and they see
the vision of of let's say you know
mother mary in their room
um and they might think well how am i
seeing
this image of mother mary and you know
is that real and and what's going on
here
whereas the full psychotic break is
oh hi mother mary how you doing you know
so nice of you to visit like
there is just no filter anymore that is
that is able to say that this
this product of my mind is in fact the
product of my mind
or or could have you know some other
explanation that it just
that that filter completely disappears
and and that's pure delirium
um and we're skirting around this a
little bit i think you might have
mentioned it but um
in the in the subtitle of this text on
the previous one
it's called capitalism and schizophrenia
so
the critique of this state is not uh the
first move they make
it's sort of the last move and to get
that as the purpose of this text would
be to be
reading it backwards a little bit so
could you compare this a little bit to
the neo-marxist method of critique
that's going on in france
at roughly the same time as this to
which
uh the critique of the state is almost
the first or the central
move that they're trying to make so how
would you compare
this critique or elaboration of the
machines of capital
and that version of surplus value versus
the delusion guitare
critiquing psychoanalysis and then
kind of answering the marxist question
in a very different way from the
neo-marxists would have
yeah so look i think perry anderson's
work on
western marxism which he was writing in
the 1970s as well
so what he says is that really the
essential problem for
most marxism at that time
was first of all we have to overthrow
the state
in order to install a marx estate but
whoops
that didn't work out and now we can
barely conceive of that as being
possible
so now marxism exists in in a kind of
period of defeat um
and you know david harvey says something
very similar he basically says
now that insurrection and revolution are
literally inconceivable
like you can look at all the people that
are marching in black lives matter and
and the various protests and so forth
that have been going on in the us
all of which are super important but the
minute they would have become
an armed insurrection the the
the power of the of the us military to
put that down
is so phenomenal it's literally
inconceivable
and there is no state or country
anywhere in the world
that has sufficient power to rise
against
the you know the us military machine and
no
organization within any country that
actually has sufficient power to rise
against the military the military
control
the means of death to such an extent
that um
you know insurrection and revolution is
has become more or less inconceivable in
our time
so if if we accept that as being just
you know a straight out fact of our life
then what does revolution look like now
and it becomes kind of disappointing
because you sort of think well basically
if i can't revolt against the state
all i can do is either complain about it
or
try to change it right like just to to
go for reform and delis
basically says both reform and
revolution are unsatisfactory neither
are going to take us anywhere
and so you're like well what is there
left to actually do
um so a lot of the i think the weak
readings of
of foucault's notion of governmentality
and and this has been really dominant
particularly in australia and cultural
studies
has been to say well the only thing left
to do is to help government
develop better policy um and so there's
all these
all these people out there doing very i
think significant
and useful research trying to better
understand what it's like to be a
prisoner better understand
the welfare needs of people living in
certain situations et cetera et cetera
you know the list is absolutely endless
um and and
what they're trying to do is is to come
up with
um evidence and ideas and facts and so
forth that they can present to
government to say you could do your job
better
if you were to take on board this
information and so they're no longer
interested in trying to reform the state
to overthrow the state or whatever
they're sort of in this business now
of trying to help the state do a better
job of whatever job it's supposed to be
doing
um i think what both delos and foucault
were asking was well you know why is the
state or as it currently is this
government
why is that the kind of necessary body
to to look after our lives and to
maintain our lives
and that's really what foucault was
saying with the idea of biopolitics
biopolitics arose and grew out of the
idea
that for the state to do its job it
needed to know
a kind of infinite amount of of
information about people
and that it uses this knowledge in order
to better govern us
um but de les mortaries question was was
slightly different
which was something like this how did
desire
come to um be formulated such that we
desire this the kind of current state of
oppression that we have
which is not to say that if we were to
desire differently we would suddenly
overthrow the government
because we know that that's not possible
but rather if we look back
far enough we have always been complicit
with the state of affairs in which we
currently exist and i think that is a
really important and powerful kind of
critique not because it's going to be
earth-shattering
and it's going to lead to a revolution
and we're suddenly going to change the
world
but rather because i think once you
start to look at um
you know what's happening particularly
in the us but certainly in australia as
well
for me the great book i don't know if
you've read this but by
dunbar ortiz's book the indigenous
history of america
literally fantastic book i mean really i
recommend it to everybody if you haven't
read it and you live in a settler
colonial country like the us or canada
or australia then you really
ought to have read it but what she shows
and and it's absolutely
incredible is just the degree to which
you know
racism was at the foundation of these
countries
you know like the whole premise of the
country was to steal land
and to set up these divides between
those who were allowed to have land or
those who are not allowed to have land
and for me like this is about going back
to the foundation of a particular
country and a whole
body of laws and a whole way of setting
up government structures and saying well
if we were really really obviously
racist at the very outset of the country
surely the only way to address this is
to go
back to the foundations of our laws and
change them
and say you know we acknowledge that
these were racist laws from the outset
um and we're going to change them so in
an australian context
for me i have always thought this would
be this would look something like this
if we were to acknowledge um at a
government level that australia is built
on stolen land
the only way we could go back we can't
un-make australia right
that's the thing we set the colonialism
we can't overturn
you know what has already happened but
you can address the premise of it
and so the premise of australia the same
in the u.s and canada
is that the land was simply stolen but
what if we were to go back and say well
actually
no we know that we stole it but we would
like to
kind of you know address that by saying
well let's say
from now on it's going to be shared land
what would that look like and what would
the foundation of laws look like
if there were laws whereby we
acknowledged the original owners
as being our hosts and that we were here
as guests
then how would we behave differently you
know and you can look about
look at this in terms of a very small
scale kind of example
but if you know a friend comes to stay
at your house
what are the rules of hospitality how do
you expect them to behave
you don't expect them to come in shoot
your family steal all your belongings
basically push you out the door and
occupy 95
of your house and tell you to get lost
and yet that's what we have done
and so i think we can actually say well
let's you know go back to the foundation
of our
uh respective countries and reimagine
the laws from the ground up
and imagine them on a different kind of
hypothesis not one of stolen land but
one of hospitality
and i think that's what de los and
quetario are asking us to do is to
really look at the foundations of things
and say well how how is our desire
complicit of that and clearly in the
case of stately colonial countries
there was a straightforwardly rapacious
desire for possessions for land for
wealth
that they thought they were entitled to
and didn't feel that they owed anything
to the people that they stole it from
and it led to centuries of self-delusion
of grandeur and so on so i think
for me that's what an analysis of desire
if we were to take that into history
would look like
all right so at this point we're talking
doubly about
literal territories and in this case
these
literal territories are also conceptual
categories having been
written into uh laws and things like
that
then do you think this would be a good
time to try to define
d territorialization and
territorialization because these are
both
uh central concepts to the the chapter
that i read today the refrain
how you would use those contexts to
actually i guess re-articulate kind of
what you just said
but how what is it what is the
importance of these concepts
in being a thinker um
as well as being a political actor
so i think the first thing is that for
dilemma the notion
of territory is not necessarily
co-extensive with a particular space
so they take it from i mean there's
various uh points of origin but if we
look
at the sort of ethological uh points of
origin which they take out of
animal behavioral studies what is uh
crucial about the the idea of of
territory within
animal behavioral studies is the sense
of a kind of subjective position
with with respect to uh space like this
is my space and and
as the elizabethary say my territory is
the space in which i feel
at home okay and if somebody comes into
my space
i i recognize and i experience them as
an intruder
but not everybody is experienced that
way so if somebody that i like comes
into my space i don't regard them
as an intruder um i see them as kind of
helping me to
to produce the space in which um i live
that become part of my territory
so the idea then of deterioration is
effectively
to to be expelled from or to expel
oneself from
the space in which you feel at home
now why might you do that on a sort of
personal level
um one of the things that qatari always
talks about
through his kind of idea of therapy he
says that we should be able to move
between territories
um you know the territory of the home
the territory of work
and that sort of thing and that there
should be a kind of seamless movement
between these different
territories but sometimes for you know
various complicated reasons we can get
stuck
in a particular territory and and we
find ourselves unable
to leave that territory and so that
would be like
you know i feel at home in my home space
um and when i whenever i leave my home i
feel like i'm
kind of away from home but also like
when i go into work
i treat everybody as though somehow
they're invading my home and so i
haven't actually
you know changed territories at all i've
just taken my territory with me
and obviously that creates all kinds of
problems so deterioration in that sense
is how does one leave one's territory
how does one
um find a way of moving on to other
kinds of territories
so it's not intrinsically negative in
fact fertilizing matari
it's necessary in lots of ways if i
become stuck on my racist values
how do i extricate myself from those
values what would it take to leave that
territory
so the other way we can think about
territory is territory is
a set of values a set of beliefs a set
of ideas
in which i feel at home and these can be
absolutely incoherent right
um and you know when we're doing a sort
of a
analysis of of racism i think what's
really interesting is is to try to
understand
racism as a form of territory in which
people feel at home
and to ask the question why do you feel
at home in those
sets of values and and what's really
interesting is that when you push people
on those values they are
you know both rock solid that they won't
leave them because they feel comfortable
but they're also
and they seem to know that they are
incoherent like i hate all black people
but my black neighbor is okay so there
is
you know there's just no coherence in
there and it lacks all kinds of
conviction
so how would you actually analyze that
except to say well
there is something about this set of
values that enables this person to
function in the world that they
do and so how would we deteritorialism
how would we give them a new set of
values
that would enable them to feel at home
but feel at home in a way that did not
necessitate this kind of
proliferation and production of kind of
statements of hate and
uh and so on and you know delicious was
saying well you know that that process
is slow you can't deteriorate too
rapidly because then people
you know feel like they don't have a
home anywhere at all and often that
makes them even more violent
so it's it's a slow process and that
process they refer to as
re-territorization
gives them the new home to to feel on
and i think what you see you know with
trump and so forth
um and like i think i always think that
the american elections are so important
you know the rest of us should be
allowed to vote too um because clearly
because clearly the americans don't want
to vote like [ __ ] this matters let us
vote too
we'll show you the right way to go um i
mean obviously that's just a crazier
side but i do think that the power of
america is such that
we can't just leave it up to the
americans to make these decisions
um but you know if you think about uh
you know trump
as this kind of how on earth did he
actually get elected
um and you know you drill down into it
you think well
why on earth would blue-collar workers
or even more
kind of amazingly out-of-work
blue-collar workers why would they vote
for someone like trump who
clearly has expressed zero interest
in in their future at all and will
literally do nothing to help them
how can we possibly explain that and so
this
this comes back to you know getting back
to your early questions about
uh marxism and so forth that we can't
really
understand these these kinds of
questions if we think about them solely
in terms of interest
because clearly it is not in their
interest to vote for trump if you think
i'm voting for the guy that will who
will get me a job and and so on
if we think about it that way it doesn't
make any sense but if we think about it
in terms of
what kinds of values is trump espousing
that might matter to somebody who's
feeling disenfranchised
and and you know kind of disengaged from
the world well he's saying
things about making america great he's
saying things about the priority of
america over everybody else
and and those values suddenly become
quite attractive so you can't understand
it in terms of
straightforward um you know financial
interest you have to start to understand
it in terms of cultural values and and
for me that's where desire comes into it
so i think that if we wanted to
understand the present situation
we have to bring desire into that
equation uh chris do you want to
respond to that before i ask my next
question
do you have a thought or no like i'm not
not putting you on the spot
no no no i i just um i see this from the
opposite side because um
and then when i was writing on de luz i
i got criticized
um by a lot of thinkers that see the
laws as apolitical
so i mean the peter hallwards the xiz
the
bad you and you always see you always
hear that fantastic story about baju
smashing through with his maoist friends
into liz's class and delilah's just kind
of dismissing him you know i'm teaching
please leave me your context that was in
basics
that was in 68 yes and and badou
actually wrote a paper called the
fascism
of the potato in 73. now i'm not even
joking about about um
about all of this stuff with delis and
and so like my my one question because i
struggled with this i have to admit i
struggled with this
because you know we have a lot of
friends that are
very hegelian marxists and and um
i never saw the the clear link with marx
and
and de las actually i mean darida
famously stated at his funeral
you know de lis was a marxist um or he
was one of the good marxists or
something like that but then you have
badou writing a book like the adventures
in french philosophy and
putting de luz in the map where fascism
is with with officer and stuff like that
so
i mean i how do you approach people
or how do you approach these other
thinkers like hallward
um and zizek and badu and and even
roncier ron sierra
um who was i think was a friend with
abdullah's but wrote
you know kind of not exactly the nicest
uh remarks about his work so how do you
deal with this apolitical
um accusation against delusion delizians
ian uh look i mean i i think
i always thought that um i never asked
peter about this but i always thought
peter only wrote that book
as a kind of a deal with um with verso
so that they were
from haiti and so forth you heard it
here first
i think peter peter may think that
that's completely off base and maybe it
is
but it's it's a very weak critique of
delays
you know it's it's such a weak critique
of delays that most people haven't
bothered to
even repudiate it um jesus critiques of
delays show
evidence that he never actually regulars
so again they're
they're not even worth repudiating
absolute crap
um and you know if you read enough zizek
which
you know for my sins i have done um
after a while it not only is it clear
that he never read
the losing guitaree and has no intention
of reading those matari
um he he quotes them at least
as often approvingly as disapprovingly
so there's literally you know
as my kids always say no consistency um
and you know as for as for baju i mean
there's so much bad faith there that's
just
ridiculous like his book on on foucault
sorry i'm delirious comes across as
somebody who's just kind of pissed off
that
um wouldn't talk to him anymore like
it's this
um just just for just for a side for the
readers they were writing
letters from 83 to 86 and de los said
he didn't want them published and then
instead badu went and
took the letters and wrote the book the
clamor of being sorry
this is hot so gowaffy and go off
well i mean you know dolores said to
badou apparently that he didn't want to
continue the correspondence anymore he
felt that he said everything he wanted
to say
and you can sort of imagine what that
what that conversation went like you
know something along the lines of
oh look bad you you're obviously not
listening to me um
you know i don't see any point in this
conversation continuing because it's
just pointless
um and you know buddy's response to that
was to sort of
come up with all this um sort of bogus
discussion of ontology that somehow
deloses ontology
because he believed in a university of
being somehow meant that he believed in
totalitarianism or something like that i
mean
as as a leap of thought like you know
you would tell off a grad student for
coming out with that [ __ ] you'd be
like
what on earth is this you know how would
you expect your advisors to to respond
to a claim like that
um so i've never felt that much need to
respond to budgie's responses to delays
they just seem idiotic
um and so i think that the whole
critique of
and the other one that everyone trots
out are the laws wasn't political until
he met retiree and and this is zhijic's
line then he became too political i mean
what kind of idiotic idea is that
um i mean it's completely false to begin
with if you read dulles's
earlier works they're clearly political
in a sense of trying to develop an
ontology that helps you to understand
the current state of affairs and also
you know the idea that he become only
becomes political in relationship to
retirees
is completely false because if qatari
was as political as everybody makes him
out to be
why on earth would he have wanted to
talk to dallas if devos was as a
political
as everybody makes him out to be it's
like i know the one person i really want
to talk to is the most a political
person in france
and write four books with him or
whatever it was
so it just it just doesn't make any kind
of sense like it's it's clearly bogus
um it's a story that people conjured up
that sounds kind of good so i think
really
what is much more likely to be true is
that they both
had political uh leanings and ideas and
sympathies
and and they saw a convergence of those
ideas
but more importantly they saw an
intensification of them as they came
together
all right so we've done our dunking
which i'm very happy about
that gives us that gives us sound bites
all right well you know it is my forte
of trash we've done our dunking um and i
want to
move right before we go to the refrain
if that's the direction we're headed
um i like how this conversation is
developing
rhizomatically or organically in any
case but
um when we move into the last book that
delusion katari wrote together uh what
is philosophy
then this uh what you're talking about
in terms of re-territorialization
um and not state smashing but
uh thinking within a state of affairs
that you're not going to be able to
change
like with your humanist individual
agency as a locus
and i think this applies to not just
people who want to be philosophers but
artists political subjects who want to
be effective as political subjects
and that's the notion of creativity
they talk about shooting off lines of
flight
and really when you get to what is
philosophy there's almost an
unction almost like if you hear us say
one thing
it's do this be creative don't box
yourself in
don't don't stick to one territory
become nomadic
um and all these sort of functions to
remake yourself um and how would you
reflect on that as sort of their
certainly not anti-political as we were
just discussing
but uh how do you see this as their goal
for not just
thinking philosophers in in
academics but uh for people to
uh become creative or make themselves
creative
right so i think the the in the
introduction to the book
um de los ange basically say
that you know things have gotten bad
when we start talking about people
working in marketing as being creative
that this is not true creativity this is
barbarians
at the gate so there is a kind of
defensiveness about this book which is
quite different from their previous
collaborations and so it does a number
of things but
one of the things it wants to try to do
is to
identify what we might think of as being
like this is what authentic
uh genuine scholarly creative work
looks like as opposed to marketing and
something else
um and so it's almost as if
and maybe this was in fact the impetus
um that
de less and wetaria were trying to
defend the university
and the idea of the university against
the encroachments of neoliberalism
which luckily for them they never had to
experience
um in terms of what universities look
like now compared to what they look like
when when delusion was still working in
the university which he
retired in like 87 or something um
because i was a you know grad student
starting about the time that he retired
and already then people were saying oh
the good old days the good old days
which no longer existed in 87 and i find
myself telling my
graduate students now all the old days
of the 1980s which
people at the time thought were
horrendous they thought this was the end
of everything that's holy
um so there is a sense in which what
does guateri which were
kind of recognizing was the the profound
interference into the university by the
state
in the form of trying to turn it into
something that was about
marketing that was about business that
was creativity on demand
there was a kind of instrumentalized
form of scholarship
and all of those things and and he's
clearly um de los angeles clearly
trying to carve out a space and says
well this is what
authentic scholarship and creativity
looks like
there is a set of values associated with
that which are really worth defending
and we should defend them against the
intrusions of of the market of the state
and so on and i think that aspect of the
book has never really been
recognized and talked about enough
perhaps because
at the time it was only the early days
of these kinds of intrusions but you
know as i look at what's happening in
the university sector
globally now you really can appreciate
just how much they wanted to defend
things that seem under real
um threat of extinction right now
so even though they are talking about
creativity they are also trying to say
and this is the other thing that's
really interesting in this book there is
a
a really kind of concerted attempt to
say
this is what is different about the
sciences from
the arts and from um philosophy
but there are they are doing just quite
distinct things
and that we should try to recognize
those differences and
see that the job of of creativity is not
to
um extinguish those differences but to
get a kind of creative interference
and so that's where they talk about uh
in the conclusion of the book that
actually what's really interesting
but what we also have to defend against
is the interference
at the the gaps between science
philosophy and art where one bleeds into
the other and loses
all distinctiveness um and and that
might sound like a kind of hypothetical
problem but i can tell you that at my
own university and many universities
around the world
they have all these um kind of
multi-disciplinary interdisciplinary
research
funds which which give money to groups
that can say well
you know we've got someone from the arts
someone from engineering someone from
biology someone from somewhere else
and now we're going to do all this kind
of work together and
but the principle of that work is that
there is no intrinsic difference between
what they all do and so therefore there
is a kind of profound
de-skilling of the individuals involved
and also a sort of
a de-specialization so you do creative
arts well that's kind of like
engineering so you know you can work
together or
you're an engineer that's creative so
therefore we you know and eventually
what you find happens is
engineers are doing creative work so
therefore we don't actually need
creative
artists anymore because you know they're
just the personalized engineers already
creative
you know marketing is already doing
philosophy so we don't really need
philosophers anymore because they're
superfluous and
they don't bring any money in so let's
go it sounds like the mit research lab
where they
i don't know grow leaves out of skin in
a
and then put it up on the wall and call
it art
[Laughter]
right right and and that's what's
happening but i think what does retiree
recognize before any of us
was that this would lead to the
extinction
of whole branches and fields of
scholarly enterprise
and that we would all be the poorer for
it because
what we don't need is the synthesis of
all these things
what we need is the interferences
between the differences
right so this is not really an unction
for just everybody to go
you know write a book of poetry and
self-publish it but it's more like
defending probably philosophy
specifically and the arts because
they're the most under threat from
the middle term of those which is the uh
the sciences that he was writing about
is that is that more accurate to say
i don't think he regards the sciences as
being no i i i'm sorry i meant pretty
clearly that it's it's marketing and
it's capitalism like the sciences
are under just as much threat as well i
mean look at you know america's
spectacular failure to deal with covert
um and it's not because they don't have
smart scientists they've got loads of
them you know
some of the smartest scientists in the
world work in the us
um but they're kind of separated from
government and separated from being able
to
apply any intelligence to the issues in
front of them by a whole bunch of
structures that have arisen out of
capitalism
so it's pretty clear that capitalism
marketing etc etc that's the enemy
um and that all the scholarly fields are
under threat oh yeah we could mention
that
what's it east england the east england
school of philosophies being
shut down yeah yeah just you know one
among many that have been you know
sacrificed to the greater god
but do you think that science or stem
programs are
at any risk of being shut down because i
find that in the budgets i look at
including the budgets of the school that
chris and i have taught at
that's not at all the case
like it doesn't look like it's the case
because they get money thrown at them
because you know
everybody wants to cure for cancer and
everybody wants you know some fabulous
new material or some fabulous new
computer part and so forth
so it doesn't look like they're under
any kind of a threat
but if you look at how that funding
is channeled towards them a great deal
of it particularly in the sciences comes
from
corporations uh which then means that
their
research is compromised from the outset
that they have
been basically doing instrumental
research for a corporation
they're not just doing pure research for
the hell of it you know we want to find
out what this particle does because that
would be interesting
are they doing oh we need to figure out
how to do this in order to make a better
supercomputer because you know microsoft
wanted or whatever so
they're compromised in different ways
that they look like they have pots of
money which often they do
but those monies are kind of golden
manacles can i
can i ask you just just a quick question
because this is one of my concerns with
what is philosophy um just about you
know it
it seems like a manifesto for for
creators to create
um but at some times it seems like de
les is just talking about
arbitrarily just creating for the sake
of creating so
how do you differentiate between
arbitrarily creating something
and creating something that's necessary
to i don't know to
to kind of as he says you know make the
stutter or stutter or or
shake shake the status quo
i guess what he's saying is something
like this
creativity is important but genuine
creativity
is difficult to the point of almost
impossible
and genuinely new things happen
extremely rarely
so we produce lots of things um through
our creative process
that are in some way a replication of
what already exists
which is not to dismiss it i mean it
doesn't mean that it's it's unimportant
or uninteresting
but it hasn't risen to the level of
genuinely creative
um and so i think that there is a kind
of very very high bar
put in place in what delos and qatari is
saying about what does creativity look
like like it's really hard to achieve
this level of creativity
um and so they're saying you know it's
only by bringing something new into the
world
that we're actually creative um but i
think this has a kind of political
resonance because
you know if you go back to what i was
saying before about the impossibility of
revolution and insurrection and so forth
to bring about a genuinely new way of
thinking about the world
is obviously really difficult there are
so many
kind of forces and powers arrayed
against
novelty within political ideas and more
importantly
novelty within the kind of application
of political ideas
they're actually to bring about that
transformation is
an extremely powerful kind of an event
and something that you know we
we would all um you know i guess want to
try to figure out how to do
and this is the you know the one thing
that baju does say which is kind of
interesting
um around politics is the idea of
conviction and he says
that a political idea should be as
kind of impossible to argue with as a
mathematical formula
which on the one hand sounds kind of
stupid but on the other hand if you
if you think about what a mathematical
formula is it's like you can't argue
with it right like 2 plus two equals
four
and you can debate that all you want but
at the end of the day it's still going
to equal four
so if you were able to produce a
political idea that was as
as lucid as an impossible to argue with
that like you know
that people ought to have a living wage
for example if that could be as lucid as
a mathematical formula
how powerful would that be from a
political point of view
and and that's what we're struggling
against like we can't seem to produce
those ideas
easily that just simply have that level
of traction
and i think that's where our creativity
is called upon and speaking of creation
and the creation of concepts which is
the job
of the philosopher um ian i don't know
if you know where this is said or if it
was said at all or if i made it up
and pretend that i had read it somewhere
but did delus say that his only
real original concept despite all the
ones that are associated with him you
know
body without organs the territories the
plateaus
all of these are sort of transposed from
other thinkers
but did he say that his one concept that
he had created was the refrain
uh not just him he and gwatari but yes
but did did they
say that specifically
yes yes they do say that this this is
the thing we created and we think that's
our most important great contribution do
you know where because i've been looking
for this quote all day
uh it's in either the um
the desert islands or the um the other
collection of essex okay i'll try to if
you send me an email
i will i will be able to find it for you
i can't off the top of my head tell you
where it is
it's either in that one or the two
regimes of madness it's in one of those
two for sure yeah
um for sure i would be able to find okay
so the refrain
i know your book deals with the refrain
so i'd like to take a
little bit to first of all discuss what
the refrain is just in case
you look this up in the dictionary the
refrain is like a chorus in music
or a repeated line in poetry or even
a motif uh reproduced across a painting
so i refrain
something that is repeated and do you
want to talk about this
in with respect to uh your your
work or what you're currently been
thinking about and
presumably spending a lot of time on
again
sure so the best way to think about the
refrain is
to see that the refrain is something
that is produced through the repetition
of material things so whether it's
it's it's sounds or images or whatever
but
in fact the refrain is that kind of
synthesis of those things like
the impossible to reproduce or to think
otherwise like if you think about a
chord
you're playing like three notes at the
same time you you can't
achieve that thing except by doing all
those things
all at once so the refrain is the
is that is what happens when you produce
certain kinds of repetitions um and and
what i think delezabotary particularly
interested in
is is the kind of internal necessity
that comes about through the production
of the refrain
so you know if you're thinking about
this in
in musical terms and you're thinking
like you're whistling a tune or whatever
and you think well you know what should
the next note be
um and what would be possible and what
would be impossible
and then if you ask yourself well how on
earth do i know what is possible what is
impossible because surely
in the grand scheme of things i can drop
in any note that i want
but you would know that that was not
true like if you put in some notes it's
just going to be completely wrong the
whole thing is going to fall apart
it's not going to work it would just
sound discordant
right it would sound wrong even if you
don't know anything about music
that's yeah literally discordant right
so discordant means it's
yeah and so if you're whistling
something and you you can to yourself
you know what sounds right
and that's the refrain right the refrain
is this kind of
creation of something that then has its
own internal necessity
um and if you like that's a way of
thinking about imminence too because
when you're in the middle of that
refrain
that is the structure that's imminence
that is pure imminence and that
structure itself determines what comes
next what should be next
and that's the creative mentality like
when you're in the zone where people
call that being in the zone
then you kind of know what the next
thing should be
and that's the refrain at work it's the
sheer imminence of that space that you
have created
through the repetition of certain kinds
of notes and then
and the creation of a structure that
enables you to decide what should be
next and what can't be next
but i mean um that's i agree absolutely
but a lot of a lot of the musicians that
delis loves
berg bless um there's not a lot of
repetition there's a kind of a lot of
free play a lot of
like the any space whatever the um
especially with bullets
um we had a he had a he wrote a lot
about bullets
but when he's talking about ballet i
mean repetition of music is not just
simply the repetition of notes
it can also be the repetition of beats
right so it can be
the repetition of a particular structure
a sequencing of beats
um and so musical composition has and
i'm
by no means an expert of course but i
know enough to know that musical
composition has a number of different
levels but what's more important is is
this
is the creation of a kind of internal
necessity whereby you know
what must come next and what cannot come
next
and and that is important like you
listen to his music i'm not a huge fan
but nonetheless when you're listening to
it
you don't sort of expect that the next
thing will be the sound of an asteroid
hitting the earth
you can kind of know what the next thing
might be so
it has its internal necessity it creates
its own space of imminence
um that progresses and develops that
makes a lot of sense because um
the one the one aspect where he starts
talking about birdsong
about the i forget the musician
um that does this um that writes whole
songs um as if you know copying the
sound of birds
i can really see the internal necessity
in regards to that
so this concept of the refrain he
actually uses
in the chapter an example of bird song
as territorializing which is another
concept we've already mentioned today
in terms of what we talked about the
other week chris about vitalism and how
action is not specifically human he's
also making a
post-humanist philosophical move in the
sense of saying this is not
just a music a music item that humans
invent
but birds use the refrain to mark
territories and it has this whole
concept of not being associated with the
eye and the ocular centrism
of western philosophy since plato it's
saying let's think in
audi audio terms or musical terms rather
than thinking of
forms and identities so it seems like a
really
centralized concept that kind of unifies
everything around it
in a few ways yeah and that's certainly
how they
think of it and it becomes so the
refrain then is the foundation of the
concept of the territory
the territory they say is the first form
of the concept of the assemblage
um and the assemblage is the you know
the sort of the first form of later
concepts that developed
out of that um that kind of grow in
scale and complexity so
you know if you wanted to find the kind
of the grounding point for them then it
becomes this idea of the refrain
but they also connect that refrain to
notions of desire because
the refrain is a way of uh
organizing desire so within the kind of
ecological context
and birds and so forth it's about mating
rituals but those mating rituals are
also about
saying um you know it's an invitation to
somebody to join that particular
territory to be part of that same kind
of way of thinking
it's also a kind of warning to all the
other um
would-be competitors and contenders to
stay away
so that desire is intrinsic in though
those kinds of sounds
yeah and i can hear uh the birds outside
declaring
their territories at the moment but if
we move
instead from i guess this is ecological
context in terms of
you know bird song what most people hear
in terms of the refrain and this will
probably connect to your discussion of
desire that you just made but how does
this connect to
something like pop music which uses the
refrain in hooks
and uh and you know melody
um and and yeah this becomes very much
integrated in
your mind right it's like super
interesting to ask yourself
why is this song a hit why is that song
not a hit like what is the ex you know
what is the difference in the quality of
the way that song is produced versus
that song that's produced
it's almost impossible to understand and
if you don't think about it just
in terms of whether it sold millions of
copies or whatever but think about it in
terms of
did it have an a form of affect of
resonance such that
you know 50 years later people are still
singing that song
and still you know kind of developing
memories and associations with that song
it's quite extraordinary like it's
really an extraordinary thing that our
culture has produced these like
three-minute pop songs
which we think of as being just you know
kind of throw away commercial things but
they're not like they
they're an important part of the way by
which we structure our memories and our
desires
in contemporary society um and
you know that's for me those are the
kinds of refrains and
and questions that become really
interesting well how do those songs
function to structure memory structure
desire
to structure the ways in which we
communicate to each other and so on
um and it's been like really interesting
to see all the bands
that have come out recently and
wanted to prevent trump from using their
music
you know so like tom petty's estate said
you can't use i won't back down and and
various other bands have done as well
and i was reading recently apparently um
buick offered
the doors a whole bunch of money in 1967
to use one of their songs to
advertise their cars and jim morrison
said if you do that
i'm going to buy a buick and i'm going
to publicly smash it
and set it on fire and tell everybody
what a [ __ ] car it is
and so they so they never used um
the door song and basically door songs
have never been used for commercial
purposes
since then but you know it's not we kind
of think of that as being
about the band's authenticity and sure
that's part of it but is it not also
about a sort of stronger sense that
these songs do
have an incredible capacity to
harness and to galvanize desire and and
you know
those with tire explicitly say you know
we march to our deaths on the tune of a
song
there's something very powerful about
this he loved edith pf
right i think i'm pronouncing her name
right he loved
just her he loved the her pop songs
but he loved just the way that her voice
would go off
tuned sometimes like he you see him kind
of
his eyes kind of like light up when you
when you when he
when you bring up her yeah it's what
roland bart referred to
as the grain of the so we've talked
about this term um
in terms of music which is what it's
closest to but it's also a concept
for how to think philosophically and
presumably how to write philosophically
because that's how you
think so what would be other
applications that don't have to do with
music
or to do with writing or anything
right so i can give you a different
completely different kind of example um
i'm working with a colleague at my
university uh gordon
wade who's in human geography and we've
been working on a project relating to
cycling
and so over the last month or so we've
been working on this
article using the idea of the refrain
and of territory to think about cycling
and so within that chapter on the
refrain they talk about this notion
of critical distance and so critical
distance is the space between
um uh creatures of the same species and
creatures of a different species
and and what is the right distance
between them so like you know i guess
the the global pandemic um has made us
super conscious of what critical
distance looks like and we all get told
to
stay 1.5 meters or two meters away from
people of our own species and so forth
whereas previously we never used to
think about that too much but if we came
up against a lion
we'd be like well you know two meters is
probably not enough distance
i want to be a lot further away so if
you think about this in terms of cycling
the way by which the regulation of um
traffic
is organized uh in australia and and
also i rode around in toronto a lot and
i was
people told me that writing in toronto
was scary but i was like this is
a paradise compared to australia
we got lanes now we got lanes on every
street in downtown so
well i was i was constantly shocked i
would be walking along and i'd get to an
intersection
and cars would stop to let me cross like
in australia that doesn't happen
like cars do not stop to let you cross
if you want to cross you wait for the
lights to change
or you just take your chances but they
certainly ain't gonna stop
um and so this idea of traffic then
either treats
all vehicles on the road as the same
species
in which case then it's just a question
of distance between them
or they're treated as a different
species
which then produces a different set of
problems which is the elizabethary think
about in terms of function
but for us are in terms of whether or
not you should be there or you shouldn't
be there
so if they are of the same species then
to me and this is the analogy i use in
the paper it's like saying
it's perfectly fine to have the fox and
the chickens in the same coop
because all you need to do is paint a
white line down the middle of the coop
and you know the chickens are going to
be safe we know that's completely false
um but that's what they do with with
bikes right they got
trucks and buses and cars zooming along
at 50 60 kilometers an hour and you've
got a white line that's
supposed to magically defend you from
that which you know
it doesn't you go across your line you
die
so that's a problem or alternatively and
this is more how it is in australia
the the position is rather something
like well the chicken should never have
been in the in the coop with the fox to
begin with because it was clearly the
fox's coop
and the chickens ought to have known
that and they should never have been
there
um and if they get eaten by the fox that
was their own fault because they
shouldn't have been there
and so in australia they're kind of
there's a real uh
trajectory to try to push bikes off the
road completely not just onto separate
lanes but onto
separate bike paths and ideally onto
trails in the bush or something but just
you know
get out of their way um and so for me
it's quite interesting to begin to think
about the space of the road as a
territory
because the founding question is i think
false
in if we assume that they're all just
traffic that's a false assumption
so therefore if we don't assume that
they're all trafficked we ask ourselves
what is the actual
state of relations between bikes and
cars and trucks and buses
then we realize that actually it's it's
a predatory relation it's a relation in
which we
acknowledge tacitly that the truck has
right-of-way because it could kill us
okay and and all our traffic laws are
premised on this idea that the thing
that can kill you
should be given right away that if you
want to cross the road then you're an
idiot you should
keep out of the way of the truck you
should have priority because it's doing
important work
and whatever so for me this this idea of
the territory then becomes a way of
questioning the foundations
of something as basic as traffic
all right so we have two examples of uh
refrains in process and it seems to be
something about the
generation of patterns either generation
uh in your in your mind or the
generation of
complex human organizations um and you
mentioned to me
in our pre-pre-discussion chat that you
were
focusing on this chapter a little bit in
your book so with the
last little bit of time we have left uh
could you give us a preview
of what your thesis is what people can
look forward to
and maybe how this concept of the
refrain fits into the thesis that you're
developing in that
yeah so the book itself is is about the
idea of
or the possibility of using the concept
of the assemblage to do
um forms of cultural analysis and um
and critical work um i
talk about the idea of the territory as
one of the
ways for which the assemblage presents
to us um
and i use the example of the kids film
cars which maybe you have seen or maybe
not but
i must have seen it about we both have
we both have nieces and nephews so
i i think we've both seen it too
yes when when that film came out my son
was about three or four and he
absolutely loved that movie
um so i just i got to watch it many many
times
um but i remember at the time i mean i
quite like the movies there's lots
that's good about it
but what was really striking to me was
them walking around supermarkets
and seeing like cans of baked beans with
images from cars on it
and and wondering you know what is what
is the correlation between those two
things
how do the kids look at that and does it
make them think that the baked beans are
going to taste better because it's got
an image of the cars on it
i don't know um and i tried asking my
three-year-old but he was of course
useless
as as three-year-olds are um why
why do you want this thing right and
they're terrible co-investigators
um on the other hand they are super
interesting too because they kind of
point you towards things you might not
otherwise have paid any kind of
attention to
and so i became really fascinated about
how do these things function in a
marketing
sense and i started to think that really
what they do
is create territories and the reason i
think this is because
like if you try to um like if you watch
kids playing with with
toy versions of cars and so forth they
don't really kind of try to
replicate the movie in any kind of way
but they take
they take ideas and and
almost concepts from the movie which
they then use and recombine in their own
kinds of ways
so it seems to me that what's important
is that the film somehow creates a kind
of territory that that their desire can
occupy
it it's a kind of an imminent space in
which cars
can talk and cars can do crazy things
that they
they know that they don't do in reality
and this
enables them to occupy that space so
that the toys then become
kind of props that enable them to create
and occupy this space and that
seems to me that's how the advertising
works and i think also what's really
interesting is that we tend to
in my view not pay enough attention to
the notion of character
like it seems to me character is the
formation of a territory
we always think of character in plot
terms but if you talk
to people about films particularly film
franchises that they that they like
like in my family we're mad fans for the
whole
fast and furious franchise because
they're just so
super hilarious um and and whenever
we're driving
we always have this kind of um refrain
family
right family yeah exactly family but
also
what would dom do in this situation
i'm stuck in a traffic jam what would
dom do and i always use oh i'll just go
over the curb and i'll just go up on the
footpath and i'll get around these cars
and everybody like yep don would do it
um but that's that's extracting notions
of character and it becomes then
a kind of a territory that we can occupy
and it becomes a sort of
imminent space for the imagination and i
think to me
that's what's really fascinating i i and
i think that's why films work like
that's why we're interested in them
if you talk to kids and watch them
playing out there's you know various
versions of
you know frozen or whatever that's what
they take they don't really give a [ __ ]
about the storyline the storyline is
fairly immaterial to them
the storyline just creates the occasion
for these interesting characters
and what they do is take the characters
off on new journeys and
and new kinds of adventures for them for
themselves
and to me those are territories um and
and that's how i
try to think about them in the book
because as these are territories and we
should be interested in the production
of territories
and then ask well what kinds of um
investments of desire do we make into
these territories um
and you know that's to me how
contemporary popular culture works
yeah i i was as you were talking i was
thinking about the cinema books and
when when doula starts talking about the
the western and i was thinking and when
i think of westerns
has nothing to do with westerns actually
i think of the 80s fighting movies you
know
that you you first you have dolph
lundgren and then you have
um steven seagal and then you have
jean-claude van damme
and it's always one person against the
world it's it's all of these
and you know even sylvester stallone and
then finally we get this new movie the
is it called the expendables the
expendables and they
they give us a whole montage of just
like every
single one you grew up with in the 80s
with all of these and they're all doing
the same thing and
because there the the territory of the
one person against the world
is completely drawn away so you you have
oh no it's just
eight different people acting like
individuals against the world
um but it is also that you know that's
the kind of thing we did as kids like as
kids we would say i imagine if you know
superman and batman had a fight and how
would that go
and now we have those movies like it's
this it's people who grew up as kids
going what if we did this with that
character and did that with that
character
and and now we're getting the film
versions of it which are i always
you know basically disappointing because
they can never be as good as what we
imagined as kids would happen if you
were to have batman versus superman or
whatever that
they kind of overlay with too much adult
crap um
and and not just the pure fun of what
those characters themselves might do
so is this um is is most of the book
this
kind of developing through uh
contemporary examples film
do you have any other examples you want
to throw at us while we close out
right so no not really disappointingly
it's not really a book about popular
culture these are some of the examples
that i use the other example that i use
from
film is the um the denzel
washington character in the professional
and talk about the the way by which he's
his character is created through a set
of
um like there's a refrain there
of the of the kinds of characteristics
so they say like if you want to
distinguish between all the various you
know military trained characters that
are revenge oriented
so liam missing liam neeson in the taken
series and and so on
john wick of course john wicks right
right
what distinguishes them is not their
capacity to kill people
um because that's more or less you know
kind of evenly distributed
rather what distinguishes them is their
kind of mental tics
right so the denzel washington character
is always polishing his apples and he
always
starts his stopwatch before he starts
punching people and he stops his stop
watching
okay so in north america it's called the
equalizer i think
all right so i probably got the name
wrong but the equalizer yeah
um yes i think the same character back
in the day
played both uh uh anyway it doesn't
matter i probably just got it wrong
um but yes those kinds of of um
character traits like what is it what is
the point of those character traits
um but clearly they're necessary to
distinguish them otherwise you just have
these kind of inhuman killing machines
because they don't have any particular
moral position etc etc it's all just
about revenge and so on
so these character traits are quite
important they really play a very
particular kind of role
which i think we need to begin to think
about and for me
it comes back to this idea of territory
of creating particular kinds of
territorial spaces so what we could get
out of that is
these ticks differentiate specifically
the protagonist
as they're a real person they're not
just a killing machine whereas everybody
that's running up the stairs and getting
shot they don't have any of the they're
not
they're not isolated or individuated as
a territory
so we're we have sympathy for one
because of the refrain
except for the villain so as umberto
echo showed with
um the bond films in a very famous essay
from the 1970s
you know he says all the all the
villains in bond films are sexually
aberrant
they all have you know these various
character traits in other words
um which you know people have read to
say well that this demonizes
these various forms of sexuality which
is undoubtedly true
but in terms of how it was i think
trying to function it was also trying to
say well
how do we make the villain seem
particularly villainous
how do we make them seem you know a
worthy adversary
for what the hero is trying to do and
what kinds of investment
investments of desire can we attract
towards it
the other thing that i do say about
popular culture in my book and i guess
this is a good one to finish
with i took my kids to
disneyland in florida in
2017 just at the time
when trump was being inaugurated so it
was a really interesting time to be a
kind of you know cultural studies
critic wandering around america thinking
you know what the [ __ ] going on in
this country
but what was really interesting to me
about disneyland
was this was the the new star wars park
had not yet been built but it was in the
process of being built but already
there were disney things happening on
the in the park
but what was interesting to me was that
the most dominant
most kind of um prevalent and pervasive
image from from the whole star wars um
uh uh franchise was the stormtroopers
like i really thought disney it would be
all about the rebels that it would be
luke skywalker and and so on and so
forth but no
it was darth vader it was captain phasma
it was storm troopers
and like every half hour or something
you'd hear that
and then have all these imperial storm
troopers marching around the park
and to me at first this seemed utterly
incongruous
and then i thought but then if you think
about it trump's about to be inaugurated
what is the most dominant image that
america has of itself right now
it's as an empire like it seems to me
that it's not
actually that surprising that the
imperial side of star wars
should be attracting all this investment
of desire
um because in the country that is the
the most powerful
empire in known history um and so i
think that there's a really interesting
thing to be
thought about there because when i was a
kid when star wars first came out
there is no way as a kid you would want
to wear
a darth vader mask or a stormtrooper
mask whatever
you know those were just absolutely the
bad guys no you know you'd have to take
turns at being the bad guy no i wanted
to be a storm trooper because you know
they were terrible
but now like they can't shoot right they
can't shoot
yeah i think um in the mandalorian
that's saying done by tycho is is
absolutely brilliant with these two
two stormtroopers they're trying to
shoot a can or something and they just
both keep missing it
absolutely it's a brilliant sort of fan
generated kind of moment
in in film but yeah when i was a kid
like nobody wanted to be darth vader
nobody wanted to be the bad guy everyone
wanted to be the rebels
luke impossibly was regarded as a hero
that you might want to be
um i mean when you watch luke now and he
seems so whiny you're kind of like well
i guess
i can see why people would rather be
darth vader i wanted to go to toshi
station to get
some to buy some power converters
he's like ridiculously whiny for this
hero you're like oh i'll never get off
this island
or this planet or whatever and just
think i'm whining kid how are you going
to become a hero
um but yeah this kind of prevalence of
the of the end
of the imperial aspect and the dark side
and everything right in the heart of
disneyland the happiest place on earth
it's meant to be all about american
values to me that that was the image
that summed up
uh my trip to the u.s at that point in
time and and
i tried to say a little bit about that
in the book and probably not enough but
i think there's a
there's a whole other project to come
back to um around this that would be
trying to trace the investments of
desire in american popular culture all
right well i think that's a perfect
image to end it on because that can be
refrained into people's minds
so that's the book that's coming out
this year september but
if you like this thing to ian he's got
many more books
including the only one i can personally
recommend which is delis
on the internet plus about what 13 years
of journal entries or so
uh longer if i'm honest i mean i mean of
yours
of your journal that you've you're
editing oh right yeah
um yeah i guess so it's better i think i
saw it was on
13. anyway um so thank you very much
uh to ian thank you chris and
uh we are going to thanks for having me
thanks for having me this is great this
was
excellent ian as our first celebrity
guest i i couldn't i couldn't be happier
totally thrilled yeah me too thank you
both
and so from the pillpot we
are out goodbye
[Music]
you